one of the things that is unfortunately
missing right now in the sort of
national discussion around almost every
issue in media but in particular around
some of the covet disinformation
is just like simple gut check questions
what do i mean by that what am i talking
about well
all the talk about religious exemptions
to the covet vaccine well some states
allow religious exemptions some don't
some organizations allow religious
exemptions some don't
a basic question that you would think is
like the first question you would ever
ask when someone says i object on
religious grounds to the vaccine
would be oh
what is your religion
what is the objection
and what other vaccines does it apply to
right when someone says well i i my
religion
is in conflict with the covet vaccine oh
okay
well
where does it say that and
does it also object to the mmr vaccine
does it also object to the hep b vaccine
what is the objection
tucker carlson yesterday hosted
fighter pilot lieutenant colonel scott
duncan who explains
i am battling the military for a
religious exemption
from having to get the covet vaccine all
right well let's take a listen to what
he had to say and keep those questions i
mentioned in mind well here's one of the
sadder stories which we did more the
scott duncan is a fighter pilot he's
lieutenant colonel united states marine
corps he has filed a religious exemption
to the military's vaccine mandate it has
not been approved right now it's on
appeal
so far the us military has issued just
two religious exemptions total
if
mr duncan's appeal does not succeed he
will be discharged from the military
which will likely lose hundreds of
experienced pilots due to this mandate
lieutenant colonel scott duncan joins us
tonight
thanks so much for coming on and i think
of the experienced pilots
that the us military marine corps this
country stands to lose you've got to be
you know in the top quartile for
experience that you've flown over 300
combat missions over 200 carrier
landings
i you know you got to kind of wonder
who at the military is prioritizing
a vaccine over that kind of experience
defending the country but um
what's your conclusion well thank you
sir yeah thank you for the opportunity
to join you tonight
specifically to be able to convey our
personal experiences and just understand
that as an active duty service member
these views are not held by the united
states marine corps or the department of
defense but we do believe that yes we
have a reasonable argument we've asked
our leadership immediately as well as
our congressional leadership to inquire
as to
really the cost-benefit analysis of
losing several hundred very qualified
aviators the average timing grade for
those aviators is 14 years and also to
just consider the second and third order
effects and consequences
of what they have to offer i'm not
unique in my situation there are many
incredibly qualified individuals with a
tremendous amount of experience and we
believe that that could be a detriment
to national defense in the event we
separate that many aviators yeah i mean
you could make a lot more flying
corporate or for the airlines than
you're making now you and all the rest
of these guys so you got to think you're
doing this for a reason a noble reason
let me ask you about the grounds
of the exemption that you're requesting
it's a religious exemption
yes sir
how would you characterize your the
problems that you have with the vaccine
well the problems we had personally with
the vaccine and we understand there's a
reasonable disagreement
we do disagree with the pedigree and the
technology maturation over time
that's one issue the other is just a
conviction by the holy spirit and i
believe we are led in that fashion and
we do not have any peace about the
vaccine itself so so think about that he
says it the technology pedigree and the
va so what he said there is complete
mushmouth mushmouth nonsense
but
it could also apply to a whole bunch of
other vaccines that he clearly accepted
because he's in the military and the
military is one of the most vaccinated
groups of people in the united states
adam kinzinger the republican
congressman tweeted about this and he
said
i'm having a hard time squaring
how you can be religiously opposed to a
covet vaccine but took the anthrax
smallpox flu
typhoid
yellow fever mmr etc to join and remain
in
and that not have violated your religion
this is a very important point
we have to be able to say
uh lieutenant colonel
what you just said doesn't make any
sense
first
where in your religious texts does it
say that this vaccine is not okay and
how would it not apply to the list of
vaccines everybody in the military gets
at basic training adenovirus we have the
list up on the screen from newsweek hep
a hep b
flu mmr meningococcal poliovirus tetanus
diphtheria varicella and then depending
on your particular occupation
anthrax hemophilius influenza type b
japanese encephalitis pneumococcal
rabies small okay i could go on
explain exactly what this means because
the truth is and i'm not being facetious
here
if there is a real basis here and i know
that by real we're talking about
religious texts which are only relevant
to those who follow that religion
why would an atheist or a buddhist
consider
what the catholic religious texts say
that they wouldn't and i understand that
that this is all self-professed stuff
but if you're going to profess it at
least show me where the texts say
it's a no on covet
but it's a yes on these 10 other
vaccines it's not being asked and even
tucker when he says explain to me
the genesis of this objection he says
well it's the pedigree and the
technology and dude that doesn't mean
anything and we should be able to say
and and i know that these are considered
it's considered offensive sometimes to
ask these questions because it's their
religion but if they are asserting
imposing religion
onto a civil system
then it should be allowed to ask obvious
questions like all right explain it to
me where where what's the passage or
give me some
some verse or explain explain it to me
so that then i can understand what it is
that you're saying and of course it
doesn't make any sense
this guy's got 10 15 vaccines clearly
because he's been in the military but
this one violates his religion we
shouldn't allow it just because someone
says it's my religion we should actually
get the information if you disagree with
me let me know you can find me on
twitter at deepakman we're going to take
a very quick break and be right back